der Krieg in der Ukraine tritt in eine
neue Phase die russischen Besatzer
werden vor allem im Osten und Süden
zurückgedrängt Putins erste Reaktionen
darauf waren die teilmobil-machungen und
die Annexion von vier Regionen nach
seinen Schein Referenten was folgt noch
der EU-Außenbeauftragte Borell warnte
heute vor einem möglichen
Atomwaffeneinsatz Russlands wie ernst
muss man die Drohungen aus dem Kreml
nehmen und wie solidarisch bleibt der
Westen wenn es bei uns richtig kalt wird
Ukraine auf dem Vormarsch wie geschwächt
ist Putin unser Thema in der Phönix
Runde
Phoenix Runde
guten Abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
Berlin und das sind meine Gäste
Professor Alexander Liebmann ist bei uns
er ist Politikwissenschaftler mit
Schwerpunkt Osteuropa und Russland an
der Freien Universität in Berlin er ist
geboren in Moskau seit 2005 in Berlin
und aber nach russischer Staatsbürger
und bei uns ist Paul Anton Krüger er ist
Korrespondent im Berliner parlamentsbüro
der Süddeutschen Zeitung und wo war
vorher auch stellvertretenderleiter des
Ressorts Außenpolitik das dann
Schwerpunkt Prof Gerhard mangold ist
zugeschaltet er ist
Politikwissenschaftler mit den
Schwerpunkten internationale Beziehungen
und Sicherheit im Post sowjetischen Raum
und er lehrt an der Universität
Innsbruck
und herzlich willkommen Ludmila Melnik
sie ist Senior Projektleiterin am
Institut für europäische Politik
verantwortlich für den Bereich Ukraine
und Moderatoren des Podcasts Ukraine
Memo mit ihnen würde ich auch gerne
direkt beginnen Frau Melnik wir haben
diese Berichte ja jetzt gehört dass nach
und nach gebietet zurückerobert werden
von der ukrainischen Armee überwiegt da
die Freude über die militärischen
Erfolge oder ist es auch gibt es auch
eine Angst der vor einer weiteren
Eskalationsstufe die das bedeuten könnte
die Freude überwiegt das zeigt auch dass
die ukrainische Armee professionell
agiert und das die Waffenlieferungen
seitens des Westens auch ein immensen
Beitrag zu dem Sieg der Ukraine leisten
ich glaube man ist schon in der Ukraine
dessen bewusst dass
Putin sich noch nicht abschrecken lässt
und man hat weiterhin sehr stark dass
der Westen die Ukraine unterstützen wird
aber heutzutage wird über viel das jetzt
gesprochen aber auch über den Ansatz der
Atomwaffen und wie sollte man damit
umgehen aber diese die der Wunsch jetzt
nachzugeben ist nicht da wenn man
einfach versteht es gibt keine andere
Chance sich zu verteidigen und das ist
die einzige Chance die man hat und man
hofft sozusagen das noch mehr Gebiete
dann zurück erobert werden können ja das
ist klar für die Ukraine ist die
Eroberung der ganzen Gebiete einzieht
okay Herr mangott wie bedeutend sind
denn diese ja Gelände Gewinne die das
ukrainische Militär verzeichnen kann wir
haben auch eine Grafik da sieht man das
vielleicht noch mal etwas also die
türkisen Gebiete sind die Gebiete zu
sagen die zurückerobert worden sind die
orange-gelben sind die
die von Russland besetzt sind und
dunkelblau natürlich der Rest der
Ukraine wie wie oft ist das weil wenn
man es so sieht denkt man ist es gar
nicht so groß
und am Höhepunkt russischen Invasion in
der Ukraine hat Russland 21 Prozent des
Territoriums der Ukraine kontrolliert
durch die offensiven in Region Harke
jetzt in Don jetzt und Johannes und auch
in der Region ist diese Kontrolle um
vier Prozentpunkte gefallen es ist aber
vor allem auch militärisch strategisch
wichtiges Gebiet das hier verloren
gegangen ist etwa vor allem der Verlust
der Stadt Liman am vergangenen
Wochenende was das Tor weit aufmacht für
offensiven Richtung luhansk und Richtung
und jetzt und insofern ist das nicht nur
eine quantitative Angelegenheit sondern
etwas sehr qualitatives und das hat zwei
Effekte es stärkt die Moral der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte ungemein und
es zeigt dem Westen dass mit den
Waffenlieferungen die Ukraine nicht mehr
in der Lage ist sich zu verteidigen
sondern nach Gebiet zurückzuerobern und
das wird die Kritiker von westlichen
Waffenlieferungen im Westen sicherlich
etwas in die Defensive drängen also das
heißt die Waffenlieferungen haben
funktioniert und damit wird der Westen
stärker unter Druck gesetzt
ja sie haben funktioniert die Frage ist
wie weit wird man im Westen noch gehen
mit zusätzlichen Waffenlieferungen es
ist ja die bekannte Diskussion soll man
Kampfpanzer liefern nicht es sind ja
noch keine westlichen Kampfpanzer an die
Ukraine geliefert worden da sind die
Regierungen im Westen zwar nach außen
geschlossen aber hinter den Kulissen
nicht ganz einig manche fürchten eben
und dazu gehört sicherlich der deutsche
Bundeskanzler das mit der Lieferung
solcher Waffen ein eskalationsrisiko
denkbar wird möglich wird dass er nicht
eingehen möchte weil er die Furcht hat
dass diese Eskalation dann nicht mehr
kontrolliert werden kann das ist ja
genau die Diskussion die jetzt hier
stattfindet erlebt man wie sehr setzt
dann dieser ukrainische Vormarsch Putin
unter Druck und wir haben es heute
gehört vom EU-Außenbeauftragten ich habe
es eben gesagt diese Drohung dass man
wirklich Angst hat vor dem Einsatz von
Atomwaffen also was bedeutet dieser
Vormarsch der Vormarsch des pushin auf
jeden Fall unter Druck es wird viel
schwieriger jetzt weiter über eine
spezialoperation zu sprechen und nach
der teilmobilmach hören wir in Moskau
ganz andere Rhetorik als die die man
früher verwendet hat
auf dem Roten Platz als die Annexion
gefeiert wurde hat man vom Kampf
zwischen der dem Guten und dem Bösen
gesprochen und dem Existenzkampf für
Menschheit und sowas also Putin steht
schon ganz massiv unter Druck und das
macht die Lage sehr gefährlich weil das
erhöht tatsächlich die
Wahrscheinlichkeit das Putin auch
innenpolitisch unter Druckgerät und wenn
er keinen einzigen Ausweg sieht sind
leider alle
eskalationsmöglichkeiten offen
herr Krüger wie beurteilen sie ist diese
ja diesen Vormarsch ist das
gleichbedeutend mit einer möglichen
Eskalation und wie sehen sie dann auch
die Reaktion hier in Deutschland darauf
also ich glaube es wenn man jetzt
darüber redet ob Putin geschwächt ist
oder nicht muss man nicht nur den
militärischen Vormarsch der Ukraine
einbeziehen sondern man muss auch zum
Beispiel über die gesamtpolitische Lage
reden Stichwort Treffen der Shanghai
Organisation für Kooperation wo die
Chinesen deutliche Absetzbewegungen
gemacht haben also insgesamt Gerät Putin
unter Druck
es ist ein militärischer Erfolg der
Ukraine es ist ein Erfolg der westlichen
Strategie die Ukraine in bestimmten
Bereichen sehr gezielt zu bewaffnen um
sie in die Lage zu versetzen
hinter den Linien der russischen
Streitkräfte relativ großen Schaden bei
den logistischen Nachschublinien zu
erreichen da geht es um weitreichende
Artillerie und mehrfacher kettenwerfer
vor allem das sind die Waffensysteme die
den Unterschied gemacht haben und die
Ukraine haben bewiesen dass sie das was
Militärs das gefechta verbundenen Waffen
nennen weitgehend beherrschen anders als
die russischen Verbände wo eben
verschiedene Waffengattungen ineinander
greifen
[Musik]
ich finde gerade die nukleare Drohung
die wenn man genaueres wording guckt
Putin so nicht ausgesprochen hat Putin
macht immer Anspielungen und und bezieht
das im Prinzip auf die russische nuklear
Doktrin die unter bestimmten Umständen
den Einsatz von Nuklearwaffen zulässt
das ist ein Szenario dass man nicht
außer Acht lassen kann das haben auch
die Amerikaner zum Beispiel der CIA
Schiff gerade gesagt man nimmt das sehr
ernst man hat Russland auch auf direktem
Wege kommuniziert dass man darauf
reagieren werde also das ist nicht näher
spezifiziert man hat von einer sehr
ernsthaften ernsten Reaktionen
gesprochen die Folgen würde ohne das
genau
auszuführen damit sozusagen für die
russische Seite für Putin das nicht ohne
weiteres zu kalkulieren ist der
militärische nutzen
eines wie auch immer gearteten Einsatzes
von taktischen Nuklearwaffen ich würde
eher von substrategischen Nuklearwaffen
reden weil nichts daran ist taktisch
bringt in keinem vorstellbaren Szenario
großen militärischen Nutzen er würde
aber und da komme ich an meinen
Ausgangspunkt zurück ein massiven
Schaden eine weitgehende Isolation
Russlands im politischen Bereich nach
sich ziemlich lesen würden sich von ihm
abwenden andere Staaten die jetzt noch
Geschäfte mit Russland machen wie zum
Beispiel Indien würden unter massiven
Druck geraten deswegen glaube ich ist
die Drohung an sich das politische
Mittel um gerade den Europäern gerade
hier in Berlin klar zu machen
geht lieber nicht so weit hin und eure
Unterstützung vielleicht auch den
Ukrainern zu sagen
pusht die Sache nicht zu weit aber ein
reales Einsatzszenario sehe ich nicht
wirklich also es ist eher die Drohung
wie sehr wirkt diese Drohung in der
Ukraine formelnik also wie sehr ist es
sie lernt ja jetzt noch mal gesagt dass
man auf keinen Fall mit Putin verhandeln
soll hat das erlassen also wie ist das
eine Reaktion auch darauf dass man sagt
man will einfach noch stärker sozusagen
die die ganz klare Kante da zeigen und
auf keinen Fall zu Verhandlungen
es gibt keine Möglichkeit jetzt zu
verhandeln ich denke wir haben auch hier
in Deutschland zu wenig über Ziele von
Podien gesprochen er hat von Anfang an
eigentlich das zehn gesetzt die ganze
Ukraine zu wie er sagte zu
denazifizieren und
die Ukraine auch verstehen wenn sie
sozusagen jetzt den Widerstand nicht
leisten werden dann würde das bedeuten
wenn sie jetzt Verhandlungen beginnen
wir geben jetzt Putin und seinem System
die Möglichkeit sich wieder aufzurüsten
das haben wir nach der Krim erlebt das
haben wir nach dem minsker-abkommen
erlebte und jetzt spricht nichts
sozusagen dagegen wenn wir jetzt sagen
wir beginnen jetzt Verhandlungen und
dann zu welchen Ergebnissen würden diese
Verhandlungen führen ich glaube was wir
jetzt wir haben jetzt die Chance einen
Widerstand Botin zu leisten wir als
Westen wenn wir jetzt die Möglichkeit
Putin geben sich wieder aufzurüsten und
irgendwie die Pause zu nutzen die
Mobilisierung zu nutzen und dann
überlegen was welche strategische Fehler
da gemacht wurden dann denke ich wir
werden als Verlierer daraus rausgehen
und wir werden nicht die Möglichkeit
haben so wie ich das sehe weiter
irgendwie ein Einfluss auf gute System
zu haben aber hat man Angst in der
Ukraine vor Atomschlag also hat merkt
man wird das wird das diskutiert ja das
wird diskutiert es gibt sehr viele auch
Witze darüber es wird auch ernsthaft
darüber diskutiert es wird auch
diskutiert wie hier in Deutschland wenn
was dann wo könnte putinen solche
Atomwaffen einsetzen und
gleichzeitig wird spricht man auch
darüber dass man das ist kein nutzen
gibt gegen Militär solche Waffen
einzusetzen sondern mehr auf dann die
Wohngebiete ins als Ziel nehmen das wird
alles sozusagen diskutiert aber wie
gesagt entweder steht man jetzt bis zum
Ende
ja bitte ja ich stimme zu dass der
Einsatz seiner taktischen Nuklearwaffe
militärisch nicht viel bringen wird aber
darum geht's Putin auch gar nicht ich
hab Putin geht es darum mit einer
sukzessiven nuklearen eskalations
Rhetorik und dann nach
eskalationshandlungen die ukrainische
Führung aber auch die westlichen
Regierungen der die Defensive zu bringen
dass sie ihre offensiven gegen
russisches Gebiet einstellen das ist
noch nicht jetzt der Fall denn es ist
zwar eine Reihe von ukrainischen
kriegserfolgen zu beobachten gewesen
aber wieder Krieg ausgeht das wissen wir
noch immer nicht aber wenn Russland vor
einer katastrophalen militärischen
Niederlage stehen sollte und buttin weiß
wenn er diesen Krieg verliert verliert
auch sein Amt dann kann ich mir
vorstellen dass diese Rhetorik
tatsächlich eskaliert das Putin zunächst
eine explizite nukleare Drohung macht
ist jetzt war das ja immer etwas
verborgen das erwähnt das keinen
bewegungseffekt hat dann auch eine
demonstrative Detonation einer
taktischen Nuklearwaffe vornimmt und
wenn auch das die ukrainische Offensive
nicht zum Stillstand bringt dann traue
ich ihn zu kaltblütig wie er ist dass
seine solche Waffe einsetzt nicht an der
Frontlinie sondern gegen die zivile
Infrastruktur gegen Zivilpersonen und da
kann man dann nur hoffen dass ihm in
Moskau jemand in den Arm fällt sollte er
einen solchen Befehl geben Herr Liebmann
sehen Sie es auch so negativ dass sie
sagen das ist durchaus möglich und geht
sozusagen die Rhetorik jetzt die jetzt
davor steht geht das jetzt auch dafür
dadurch dass man dass wir darüber
diskutieren dass man auch dass man die
Angst jetzt hat dem muss ich leider
zustimmen also ich teile völlig die
Sicht dass es hier nicht um die
militärische Logiken geht nicht darum
dass man die Armee tatsächlich stürzt
aber ganz ehrlich was wir in den letzten
Monaten gesehen haben war nicht
unbedingt die überzeugendste mil Taktik
und Strategie seitens Russlands
überhaupt vom Tag 1 es geht hier um
politische Effekte und es geht hier um
außenpolitische Effekt und es geht hier
auch sehr stark um innenpolitische
Effekte wir haben zum Beispiel neulich
von dem tschetschenischen
Oberhaupt am Sand cadero direkte
Forderung gehört Nuklearwaffen
einzusetzen die öffentlich gemacht wurde
er wurde zwar vom Sprecher von Putin
zurückgewiesen mit der Aussage das ist
keine Angelegenheit der Gouverneure aber
das Problem ist hier Lenker der Krieg
dauert desto stärker gefällt Putin unter
Druck seitens der Hardliner und seitens
derjenigen die das Ende wollen desto
mehr russische Soldaten fallen in diesem
Krieg und jetzt sind jetzt keine
Berufssoldaten mehr es sind mobilisierte
desto mehr Leichen gehen nach Hause und
desto mehr Menschen werden sagen okay
wir sind bereit alles zu tun um den
Krieg zu gewinnen und dann kann es
leider passieren dass Putin
wenn er keinen anderen Ausweg sehen wird
tatsächlich eskaliert was wäre denn wenn
das so ist Krüge was wäre denn dann die
richtige Reaktion aus westlicher Seite
ich glaube das oder nein ich glaube man
muss das man muss das
so weiterspielen wie man das bisher
gemacht hat ist es ja auch nicht so dass
es das sämtliche Wünsche zum Beispiel
der Ukraine nach Waffenlieferungen
erfüllt worden sind ich glaube es gibt
einen graduellen Ansatz den verfolgt man
in enger Absprache wichtig ist dass
dabei die Geschlossenheit gewahrt bleibt
das betont ja auch Scholz immer
es ist übrigens auch so dass andere
westliche Staaten also weder Frankreich
noch Großbritannien noch die USA
Kampfpanzer oder Schützenpanzer derzeit
an die Ukraine liefern manche weil sie
nicht können beim anderen also bei den
Amerikanern würde ich sagen es ist eine
bewusste politische Entscheidung im
Moment wenn man sagt wir liefern gerade
Dinge die machen einen militärischen
Unterschied das sehen wir jetzt und wenn
die nächste Phase kommt wird man über
die nächsten Lieferungen reden ich
glaube aber man wird an dem Punkt kommen
wo man nicht drumherum kommt einfach
weil das Reservoir an an
zum Beispiel Kampfpanzern aus
sowjetischer Produktion
später erschöpft sein wird
aber ich glaube man muss weiterhin eng
beobachten wie Putin sich verhält
es wird Signale geben möglicherweise
auch bewusst vom Putin gesetzt wenn er
tatsächlich sich einen Schritt zu bewegt
auf den tatsächlichen Einsatz einer
taktischen oder substrategischen
Nuklearwaffe die sind gelagert getrennt
von von den Trägersystemen man würde
sehen dass bestimmte Einheiten aktiv
werden die Amerikaner kennen die
Koordinaten dieser Stützpunkte wo die
Waffen gelagert sind sie überwachen die
Kommunikation des russischen Militärs
also das würde nicht unbemerkt bleiben
und er kann es auch nicht alleine es
gibt drei müssten das ist bei den
substrategischen Waffen nicht so ganz
klar wie die Sicherheitsmechanismen da
sind man muss auch immer sehen diese
Sicherheitsmechanismen sind entworfen
worden um einen missbäuchlichen eine
missbräuchlichen Einsatz zu verhindern
das heißt dass jemand einen Einsatz
befiehlt der dazu nicht berechtigt ist
der russische Präsident ist dazu
berechtigt das steht wörtlich so in der
russischen nuklear-doktrin drin und wir
kennen ja die Diskussionen die in den
USA geführt worden sind
aufgedeckt von in Büchern in den letzten
Tagen der trump-regierung wo der
generalstabsvorsitzende damals irgendwie
seine Ängsten Berater zusammen geholt
hat und man überlegt hat was der
rechtmäßige Befehlshaber was man tun
würde wenn er rechtmäßige Befehlshaber
also Trump den den Befehl zum Einsatz
einer nuklearwa vergeben würde weil das
eine legitimer Einsatz wäre aber eben
vom rechtmäßigen Befehlshaber angeordnet
und das gleiche Problem haben sie
strukturell auch in dem russischen
System okay was würde denn her bitte
ich wollte das noch kommentieren also
wieder Westen damit umgehen soll ich
denke diese verdeckte nukleare Drohung
oder dann vielleicht eine explizite
nukleare Drohung die wirft westliche
Regierungen in an die Lämmer da gibt es
Regierungen die sagen
wir halten ein solches nuklearles
eskalationsrisiko für möglich wir müssen
das unter allen Umständen vermeiden und
wir müssen daher die Kriegsziele der
Ukraine die wir mit Waffen unterstützen
enger definieren als dass die
ukrainische Führung jetzt tut
bestenfalls die Wiederherstellung des
statusquote also der Frontlinie wie es
am Beginn dieses Krieges bestanden
und da gibt es andere Regierungen das
ist die andere Seite des Dilemmas die
sagen nein wir dürfen uns von Putin
nicht nuklear erpressen lassen und
nichts anderes ist das was Putin dann
tun würde die sagen wenn wir jetzt Putin
nachgeben dann bedeutet das dass jede
nuklear macht sich Territorium gewaltsam
aneignen kann und nichts dagegen getan
werden kann weil eine solche nuklear
macht dann eben mit dem Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen droht und in diesem
Dilemma zwischen diesen beiden
Positionen müssen sie westliche
Regierungen jetzt in den nächsten Wochen
und Monaten orientieren und was würden
sie ihn denn raten
und ich bin Analytiker kein politischer
Berater kein Aktivist das lasse ich den
Regierungen über was sind sich nicht
einfach ist als aus russischer Sicht
also wie erlebt man was wie gefährlich
sehen Sie es und was wenn Sie das dass
Dilemma was ja Mangold gerade
beschrieben hat
wenn sie ihn Rat geben müssten einem
Politiker wollten sie das auch nicht tun
ich bin auch ein Analytiker und kein
Berater es ist am Ende die Frage der der
Wahrscheinlichkeiten und falls wir
tatsächlich mit der finalen Eskalation
konfrontiert werden können und diese
Finale Eskalation für sehr
wahrscheinlich halten oder zumindest
wird unter gewissen Bedingungen für
wahrscheinlich halten würden Sie denn
sagen es ist jetzt wahrscheinlicher
geworden durch den Vormarsch der Ukraine
ist diese eskalationsstoffe
wahrscheinlicher geworden es ist
wahrscheinlicher geworden nicht nur
durch den Vormarsch der Ukraine sondern
auch durch die anderen Handlungen die
Putin unternommen hat durch die
Annexionen die Annex anderen geben Putin
und der hat einen etwas verwirrend
legalistischen
verwirrendealistische Art und Weise wie
er argumentiert es gibt ihn jetzt eine
Ausrede dass er Waffen verwenden würde
um das russische Territorium zu schützen
dass die Referenten reine
scheinreferenten sind dass sie von
niemandem anerkannt werden und spielt ja
keine Rolle also das hatte Eskalation
möglicher gemacht und die Mobilmachung
die den Krieg in jedes Haus loslang
gebracht hat macht die iskalation auch
wahrscheinlich macht die Eskalation
wahrscheinlich anderer sagen aber
dadurch wurde Putin geschwächt weil
jetzt auf einmal kann er nicht mehr von
der spezialoperation reden jetzt ist der
Krieg überall jetzt dann hat er
eigentlich könnte es auch sein dass er
die Bevölkerung gegen sich hat da sind
aber zwei Sachen die eher einander
unterstützen als einander gegensetzen es
ist gesetzlich sind Putin würde keine
Nuklearwaffen verwenden falls er stark
wäre Nuklearwaffen können aber dann
verwendet werden wenn Putin einfach
keinen anderen Ausweg sieht und das ist
jetzt leider
ähnlicher geworden das würde dann aber
im Umkehrschluss heißen die Ukraine
sollten besser nicht versuchen weiter
vorzumarschieren ich werde auch keine
klare und eindeutige Empfehlung dazu
sagen würde vielleicht einmal ein
bisschen weitergehen als mein mitredner
und sagen wir sprechen von extrem hohen
Gefahren hier die man auch ernst
bedenken muss Frau merkt wenn Sie das
hören wenn also diese Ansicht dass durch
den Vormarsch die Eskalation näher
gekommen ist
was können Sie darauf reagieren ich kann
nachvollziehen dass eigentlich das Ziel
dass sich Putin vorgenommen hat am
Anfang das Ziel konnte er nicht
erreichen ja wir wissen ganz genau er
hat er wollte eigentlich in drei Tagen
die
erobern und dann irgendwie eine
Regierung neuer Regierung da aus
installieren und so weiter und in der
Tat ist der in der Falle das Bier er für
sich selbst eigentlich bereitet hat die
Frage ist für uns
wofür entscheiden wir uns sollen wir
jetzt Putin helfen was er gemacht hat
oder sollen wir uns auf Fragen
ist das wirklich das was wir in der
Ukraine erleben das ist die mögliche
Eskalation oder was kommt danach wenn
wir kein Widerstand jetzt leisten ich
glaube Putin das ist nicht nur die
letzte Rede aber in vielen Reden die er
schon gehalten hat hat er auch sehr
deutlich gezeigt er betrachtet den
Westen als Feind und eigentlich das Ziel
ist die Ukraine zuerst zu erobern sich
als Imperium zu installieren und dann
versuchen eigentlich die Europäische
Union auseinander zu bringen das ist die
Zukunft und ich glaube wir sollen nicht
jetzt versuchen zu schauen was was will
er was wird er machen wir konnten zum
Beispiel den Angriffskrieg auch nicht
vorhersehen die Frage ist welche Mittel
können wir einsetzen wie können wir ihn
davon abschrecken ja mit welchen Staaten
sollen wir zusätzlich reden welche
diplomatische mit wir dann einsetzen und
vielleicht mir Einfluss auf China oder
an andere Staaten sozusagen nehmen das
ist sich glaube wichtig und was was
können wir machen jetzt damit ihr nicht
auf den Gedanken kommt wirklich auf
diesen roten Knopf zu drücken und was in
wirklich schlechter Kriege was was
könnte denn Putin wirklich Schwächen man
es gibt ja immer noch keine große
Protestbewegung in dem Land also könnte
er durch die Bevölkerung geschwächt
werden die jetzt diesen Krieg negativ
sehen wird könnte er durch Menschen die
um ihn herum im Kreml sind geschwächt
werden also was könnte ihnen Schwächen
eigentlich also ich glaube die das
wahrscheinlichste Szenario in dem
Zusammenhang und ich glaube insgesamt
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht
sonderlich hoch ist dass es bei einem
bestimmten Eskalationsstufe oder
weiteren negativen Verlauf dieser dieses
angriffskriegeskräfte innerhalb des
Systems gibt entweder in den
Geheimdiensten oder im Militär die sagen
okay das ist jetzt der Punkt bis zu dem
wir mitgegangen sind und jetzt nicht
weiter
ich glaube dass dieser Punkt auf jeden
Fall kommt ich weiß nicht wie man sich
dann verhalten würde aber
wenn es eben an den Einsatz von von
Nuklearwaffen geht das ist wäre ein
derartiger Zivilisationsbruch ich meine
Putin hat das vorweggenommen in seiner
Rede er hat gesagt die Amerikaner haben
mit Hiroshima und Nagasaki ein
Präzedenzfall geschaffen das kann man
wenn man sozusagen das negativszenario
sehen will irgendwie als voraus Allende
ja
Relativierung eines solchen Schlages
irgendwie betrachten
ich glaube aber schon dass sowohl die
Amerikaner als auch andere die Chinesen
zum Beispiel
Putin sehr deutlich zu verstehen geben
dass ein solcher Schritt nicht ohne
Folgen bleiben würde die Amerikaner
haben wie gesagt von katastrophalen
Konsequenzen geredet die damit
einhergehen würden
ja das ist ein Zeichen dass man eben
nicht bereit ist sozusagen
im Moment diesen nuklearen Drogen
irgendwie nachzugeben
es gibt auch die Interpretation dass die
im Moment vor allem taktischer Natur ist
das Putin Zeit kaufen muss um eben von
dieser Mobilisierung von dieser Tim
Mobilisierung überhaupt profitieren zu
können das geht damit los dass die Leute
die da eingezogen werden an die Front
gebracht werden müssen die müssen in die
Einheiten gebracht werden die müssen zum
Teil ausgerüstet ausgebildet werden das
ist nichts was von heute auf morgen
passiert ja und
es gibt Militär taktisch die
Interpretation dass das sein Versuch ist
sich sozusagen ins nächste Frühjahr zu
retten und dann mit einer neuen
Offensive militärisch das Blatt zu
wenden
Gott diese teilmobil machen was bedeutet
die in aus ihrer Sicht und wann ja wann
könnte das wirken also wann könnte das
wirklich das russische Militär so
stärken weil das scheint ja in vielen
Punkten sehr schwach zu sein
und Putin hat diesen Schritt einer
teilmobilisierung sehr lange
hinausgezögert weil er wusste dass der
Anschein der Normalität den in den
letzten Monaten zu waren versucht hat
dann verschwunden sein wird weil wenn
Väter und Söhne von ihren Familien
getrennt aus ihren Betrieben geholt
werden dann kommt der Krieg eben in
jeden Haushalt in Russland und das
verändert die Perspektive und Umfragen
zeigen eben auch dass der Anteil der
Russen die sich jetzt als geschockt und
verängstigt bezeichnen in den letzten
zwei Wochen deutlich angestiegen ist ich
erwarte zwar nicht dass das zu einer
Revolte von unten führen könnte aber es
ist jedenfalls sicherlich ein
Unsicherheitsfaktor im System
es wird wenn diese 300.000 Mann
mobilisiert werden sollten sicherlich
mindestens eineinhalb bis zwei
zweieinhalb Monate dauern bis die
einsatzfähig an der Front sind was
schneller gehen könnte ist das was man
im militärischer grand einen
rückwärtigen Einsatz bezeichnet das
heißt das erste mobilisierte Reservisten
eingesetzt werden in dem Gebieten die
Russland kontrolliert und dort
Sicherungsaufgaben wahrnehmen
Logistikaufgaben wahrnehmen und damit
vertragssoldaten hochqualifizierte
vertragssoldaten frei zu machen um an
die Front zu gehen aber das sind erst
erste Anzeichen das sind zum Teil auch
nur Vermutungen wir werden sehen ob sich
das tatsächlich erfüllt oder ob viele
junge Reservisten tatsächlich als
Kanonenfutter an die Front geschickt
werden Herr Liebmann ich habe zwar
gesagt sie sind russischer Staatsbürger
sie trauen sich jetzt nicht einzureisen
weil sie auch Angst hätten sie würden
eingezogen ja das auf jeden Fall ich
glaube extrem viele russische
Staatsbürger haben das Land jetzt
verlassen wir haben keine zuverlässigen
Daten darüber wie viele das Land
verlassen haben wir wissen nur wie viele
Menschen die Grenze überquert haben das
ist nicht ganz dasselbe aber
schätzungsweise sprechen wir von
hunderttausenden bis zu einer Million
die möglicherweise jetzt weg sind man
darf aber auch nicht vergessen dass es
auch die andere Reaktion in Russland
gibt und eine sehr eine Reaktion die
mich sehr zu als so zu zum zum sorgen
bringt ich höre immer wieder und man
hört immer wieder von Russen die jetzt
freiwillig an die Front ziehen weil sie
sagen dass es jetzt zu einem Krieg von
Russland geworden ist und auch wenn Sie
den für falsch halten stehen sie halt
mit ihrem Volk und wir sehen in Russland
viele Frauen die jetzt für die
soldatenkleidung
Ausrüstung und ähnliches kaufen weil sie
extrem schlecht versorgt werden von
Ministerium das auf die Mobilmachung
nicht vorbereitet war wenn sie wollen
eine Art Stockholm Syndrom setze ich
langsam kam in der russischen
Bevölkerung durch solidarisiert mit
seinem Geiseln und das kann das kann
diesem Krieg wieder eine ganz neue
gefährliche Dimension verleihen aber die
die knapp eine Million oder wie viel es
jetzt genau auch sind wissen wir nicht
aber die jetzt das Land verlassen haben
was bedeutet das denn für das Land das
sind viele junge Männer weggehen ja
überhaupt nichts Gutes wenn wir über
weitere gesellschaftliche Entwicklung
über die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
sprechen ist die Mobilmachung natürlich
hat katastrophale Folgen die
produktivsten verlassen das Land
diejenigen mit der guten Bildung
diejenigen die notwendige Berufe haben
die das Land braucht die anderen gehen
an die Front und produzieren auch nicht
und diejenigen die im Inland haben die
Produktivität sinkt da auch weil die
Menschen jetzt die ganze Zeit besorgt
sind dass sie ins Krieg gezogen werden
also wirtschaftlich wird Russland jetzt
schlechter gehen wegen der mobilnachung
ganz eindeutig das wäre eine Möglichkeit
dann doch Putin zu schwächen
ich weiß nicht was das Wort Schwächen
hier bedeutet muss ich ganz offen sagen
also die Frage ist halt ob zum Einlenken
zu bringen ja das ist das sind zwei
verschiedene Fragen also
Quotient zum Einlenken kommen in dem er
seine Ziele abwägt
und was wir leider sehen ist dass er dem
Krieg in der Ukraine eine sehr hohe
Priorität zuordnet ich teile die ihre
Sicht nicht das Putin tatsächlich auch
weitere Kriege plant oder eine Gefahr
für irgendwelche andere Länder ist also
der Ukraine ich glaube es geht wirklich
nur um die Ukraine hier ganz ehrlich
aber es ist auch so dass Putin nicht
bereit ist den ukrainischen Krieg ohne
etwas abzuschließen was er als Sieg
verkaufen kann und was für seine Logik
passt und das scheint für ihn ein extrem
hoher Ziel zu sein die wichtige Frage
ist aber ob auf die russischen Eliten
genau dieselbe schmerzensgrenze haben
und genau dieselbe Wahrnehmung von
Zielen haben das wissen wir aber leider
gar nicht
okay wollten sie daraufhin reagieren ich
was wir ich glaube schon außer Acht
lassen dass Putin versuchte nicht nur
eine Realität für den Westen zu schaffen
durch die Medien durch die Propaganda
aber auch für die eigene Beförderung wir
haben jetzt fest auch alle gesehen als
die die diese Schein Referenten in
Person und auch in saporisa durchgeführt
wurden dann war auch für Putin das Ziel
zu zeigen dass die Masse und die
Bevölkerung mitjubeln und wir haben auch
gesehen wie viele Busse eigentlich diese
Menschen nach Moskau gebracht haben um
so eine Veranstaltung zur ja zu
organisieren die Frage ist auch für mich
wenn er das alles so versucht zu spielen
ja diese neue Realität zu konstruieren
wie lange kann so eine brüchige Realität
überhaupt wirken hätte er so eine große
Unterstützung in Russland gehabt dann
wäre er nicht gezwungen gewesen die
ganze Zeit mit Propaganda zu arbeiten
diesen Menschen irgendwas ein auf die
Menschen
Einfluss zu nehmen das heißt
die Zeit rennt ihm auch weg
und ich glaube was wir müssen auch mit
Blick auf die Ukraine auch nicht
vergessen wir haben mit Schutzhelmen und
eigentlich Schutzwesten angefangen die
Ukraine zu unterstützen und jetzt sehen
wir es ist schon eine gewisse Zeit
vergangen und eigentlich müssen wir
weiter das machen und einfach schauen ob
er wirklich in der Lage sein wird all
das auch innerhalb von Russland also
unter Kontrolle zu haben anscheinend
kann er das nicht also darauf setzen Sie
dass es sowohl in der im Land selber zu
wenig Kontrolle gibt als auch natürlich
weitere militärische Verluste durch
starke Waffenlieferung aus und wenn
unser Ziel auch ist ein eigentlich ein
normales einen normalen Staat als
Nachbar zu haben ich will nicht als
sozusagen ständig in Europa leben und
einen Staat als Nachbar zu haben mit
Atomwaffen droht ich glaube das Ziel von
uns von jedem von uns ist eine
demokratische Gesellschaft in Russland
zu haben und was schwierig das kann nur
verändert werden wenn dann diese System
verändert sein wird ich würde gerne mal
nach der Solidarität des Westens auch
schauen das habe ich am Anfang auch
gefragt hat Krüger wie weit werden wir
weiter an der Seite der Ukraine so
stehen werden die die westlichen
Interessen mit verteidigen dort wenn es
zum Beispiel wenn wir weiter hier in
in dieser Energiekreise Energiekrise
kommen und es was weiß ich hier auch
viele Proteste gibt wenn Leute nicht
mehr bereit sind da das zu unterstützen
wie schätzen Sie das ein
und wenn auch auf der anderen Seite dann
auch noch die Eskalation droht durch
Russland
ja also wenn man sich die Umfragen
anschaut ist die die
Unterstützung ungebrochen die Leute sind
auch bereit höhere Energiepreise zu
tragen ich glaube da ist jetzt auch eine
Entscheidung herbeigeführt worden
durch Russland also Russland ist glaube
ich nicht davon ausgegangen
dass
in Europa und gerade auch in Deutschland
in der Geschwindigkeit in der das jetzt
passiert ist die energieimporter
reduziert werden
man hat sich entschieden den Gasfluss im
Prinzip schon auch bevor es die
Schäden an dem Pipelines durch diese
unterwasserexplosionen gegeben hat auf
Null zu drehen
damit hat der Kreml im Prinzip ein
wichtiges Druckmittel verloren mit dem
er versucht hat die EU auseinander zu
treiben
da kann es jetzt noch mal sozusagen im
Nachgang zum Beispiel der Wahlen in
Italien Verwerfungen geben aber sowohl
Melonen als auch berluson schon gesagt
ja auch dass sie da sozusagen
bei der Linie bleiben werden das neue
Sanktionspaket ist jetzt vom Umfang und
von von dem was da auf den Listen steht
mehr ein symbolischer Schritt aber die
Sanktionen wirken auch und ich glaube
die Bundesregierung hat ganz klar
gemacht mit dem 200 Milliarden Paket
dass man jetzt aufgelegt hat um eben die
Energiepreise zu deckeln
dass man die Voraussetzungen schaffen
will
dass das eben nicht die sozialen
Verwerfungen verursacht die manche
befürchtet haben und im Prinzip ist es
für den Westen vor allem für die
Europäer eine Frage ob sie bis 2024
kommen und wenn das gelingt wird halt
das Ende der Veranstaltung sein dass
Europa weitgehend unabhängig ist von
russischer Energie und
dem russischen Staat eine wichtige
Einnahmequelle wegbricht die er so
schnell nicht wird ersetzen können mit
China oder Indien gibt es zwar
potenzielle Interessenten aber eben
nicht die nötige Infrastruktur um
dorthin zu liefern da höre ich ein
bisschen vorsichtiger weil also das
Problem ist nicht dass wir jetzt ein
vorübergehenden Schock haben an dem wir
uns einfach anpassen müssen
leider kann die Unterbrechung der
Lieferketten und der Dauerzustand dass
die Energien Deutschland teuer bleibt
und so viel ich weiß gehen wir
eigentlich davon aus dass die Energie in
Deutschland jetzt in der absehbaren Zeit
teurer bleibt also nicht nur ein paar
Monate es geht nicht nur um ein paar
Jahre würde ich sagen so ein deutlich
mehr so massiven wirtschaftlichen
Verlusten kommen es gibt gewisse
Industrien die einfach keine Zukunft in
diesem Land haben wenn die Energie teuer
ist
und ich will jetzt nicht über
gesellschaftlich Verwerfungen sprechen
weil das ist einfach nicht mein
Forschungsthema es sollte man eher mit
jemandem sprechen der sich mit der
deutschen Politik beschäftigt aber ein
ärmeres und geschwächtes Europa ist auch
nicht unbedingt der beste Freund für die
Ukraine einfach deswegen weil die
Ressourcen nicht unbedingt da sein
werden die sind ja nicht was wäre dann
ihre Schlussfolgerung daraus aber man
muss einfach sehr vorsichtig sein man ja
fragen das heißt wenn man weiterhin mit
Russland handeln wird wird man dann
stärker sein und wirtschaftlich stärker
sein oder was ist denn Ukraine helfen
können das ist der Gegensatz der
Sanktionen das stimmt das heißt trotz
dessen was bereits gemacht wurde wir
erleben einen Angriffskrieg in Europa
trotz dessen sollen wir die Augen zu
machen und egal dass es um
demokratischer Werte geht die die
Ukraine verteidigt sollen wir die Augen
zu machen und mit Russland weiter
handeln weil es einfach darum geht uns
gewisse wirtschaftliche Stabilität zu
schaffen natürlich nicht aber wir müssen
bei Sanktionen zwei andere Fragen
stellen es geht hier nicht nur um
moralische hochstellung in der
Außenpolitik sondern darum welche
Sanktionen tatsächlich zu erwünschten
Wirkungen führen und wie die relativen
Kosten der Sanktionen für die russische
Wirtschaft sind und für die europäische
Wirtschaft und man muss nicht einfach
handeln weil man Handlungszwang fühlt
irgendwas tun sondern das tun was wirkt
es gibt Sanktionen die wirken da gibt es
überhaupt keine Zweifel und die müssen
eingesetzt werden aber es gibt Teile von
sanktionspaketen die einfach keinen Sinn
machen aber welche machen keinen Sinn
oder welche wirken ja es gibt kein gutes
Beispiel Sanktionen gegen die russischen
Beamten sind auf jeden Fall sinnvoll
oder ich warte auch bis jetzt auf die
Veröffentlichung die die USA schon vor
dem Krieg mal versprochen haben
Veröffentlichung wir persönliche Konten
von Putin das würde ich sehr gerne lesen
das würden auch viele Leute in Russland
sehr gerne lesen und das wäre
tatsächlich ein Effizienz Aktion gegen
die Energie Lieferung das würden Sie
sagen selbst ausge wenn es um Gas ging
da haben sie absolut Recht das hat am
Ende Russland selbst den Gashand
zugedreht in der Hoffnung dass es der
deutschen Wirtschaft Schaden wird aber
ja da sind die Kosten einfach aber das
sind ja Kosten die wir gar nicht mehr
steuern können weil wie gesagt putinen
die Entscheidung getroffen hat und aus
meiner Perspektive wird das dazu führen
dass es halt als Katalysator für andere
Energien wirken wird also es wird ein
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien in
Deutschland und in Europa geben in einem
Maß den wir uns vor wenigen Jahren nicht
haben vorstellen können es wird
möglicherweise auch andere Länder geben
die andere Entscheidungen treffen
Belgien zum Beispiel hat gerade die
reaktorlaufzeiten und zehn Jahre
verlängert da werden wir ein sehr
schnellen Strukturwandel sehen das wird
Geld kosten das stimmt schon
umgekehrt ist es ja sogar ein politisch
erwünschtes steuerungsziel die
Energiepreise
steigen zu lassen um die Abhängigkeit
von fossilen Energien zu verringern 35
gibt es Ziele 2050 gibt es Ziele der EU
was was die CO2-Emissionen angeht und da
wird es als Katalysator wirken da wird
man jetzt kumulierte Kosten haben die
höher sind als wenn es sozusagen entlang
der normalen Planung gelaufen wäre aber
ich glaube dass das auf 10 15 Jahre
gesehen
wirtschaftlich am Ende nicht dazu führen
wird dass Europa die industrialisiert
oder sonst wie geschwächt wird wie sehen
Sie das also wie stark welche Rolle
spielen diese diese Sanktionen also
worauf müsste man mehr setzen aus aus
der europäischen Sicht dass man sagt wir
müssen weiter an die Sanktionen noch
verschärfen oder wir müssen eben doch
dann sagen das lässt sich alles nur
militärisch Regeln oder vor allem
militärisch lösen
noch nicht Stimme Kollegen Liebmann du
hast zu dass nicht alles was beschlossen
wurde an Sanktionen sinnvoll und wirksam
war aber ich bin dann doch der Ansicht
dass Sanktionspolitik an sich
alternativlos war die Europäische Union
der Westen insgesamt musste auf diese
Grenze Überschreitung Russlands einfach
reagieren die Frage ist nur wie wirken
diese Sanktionen und da muss man einen
sehr differenzierten Befund eigentlich
vornehmen sie wirken sicherlich im Sinne
einer Bestrafung Russlands Wirtschaft
sein Finanzsektor wird bestraft durch
die westlichen Maßnahmen nicht so stark
und nicht so schnell ursprünglich
erwartet die Volkswirtschaft Russlands
hat sich etwas resilienter Wesen als das
erwartet worden war aber mit jedem Monat
mehr werden die wirtschaftlichen und
finanziellen Folgewirkungen drastischer
werden und was langfristig mit diesen
Sanktionen auch erreicht wird ist das
die kriegsführungsfähigkeit Russlands
geschwächt wird das heißt dass das Land
finanziell und wirtschaftlich so
deutlich schwächer wird dass ich eben
eine aggressive Außenpolitik eine
militaristische Außenpolitik nicht
leisten wird können was aber nicht
funktioniert hat und da kann die
Europäische Union 8 ist ein neuntes ein
zehntes Sanktionspaket beschließen ist
das Verhalten der russischen Führung zu
ändern Putin für diesen Krieg in der
Ukraine ungeachtet das Sanktionen weiter
und da muss man einfach sagen ihm sind
seine geopolitischen Ziele in der
Ukraine viel viel wichtiger als das
wirtschaftliche das finanzielle und der
sozialer soziale Wohlergehen des Landes
und zuletzt noch was auch nicht geklappt
hat ist durch die Sanktionen in der
Führung des Landes so eine Art
Lagerbildung zu erreichen zwischen denen
den softlinern die sagen angesichts der
Sanktionen sollten wir auch die
Forderungen des Westens eingehen und den
Hardlinern die sagen nein das tun wir
sicher nicht diese Effekt wurde auch
nicht erzielt das klingt alles so als
müssten wir uns auf einer ganze Zeit
noch einstellen in dieser Krieg dauert
ähm herr Krüger was was würden Sie denn
sagen welches Szenario wer ist für ein
Kriegsende überhaupt am
wahrscheinlichsten wenn Sie darüber
nachdenken was denken Sie wie lange wird
es noch gehen also Kriege werden in
aller Regel durch Verhandlungen beendet
das hat auch sehr lensky ungeachtet das
Gesetz ist das jetzt erlassen worden ist
das direkte Verhandlung mit Putin
verbietet immer wieder gesagt nach allem
was ich weiß von meinen Gesprächen mit
politischen Verantwortungsträgern und
auch Leuten die die militärische
Situation besser beurteilen können als
ich das kann muss man davon ausgehen
dass das mindestens die nächsten sechs
bis neun Monate weitergeht also man
rechnet damit
dass im Frühjahr sich möglicherweise die
militärische Situation noch mal
entscheidend weiterentwickeln kann bis
in den Sommer hinein es laufen die
Planungen für die Unterstützung der
Ukraine auf diese Sicht das fängt an mit
militärischen
Temperatur habt wo man von Westen
gelieferte Waffensysteme warten kann wo
man gerade guckt ob man das irgendwo in
Grenzen hier hinkriegt 6 bis 9 Monate
sagen sie letztendlich aber ein Ende
durch Verhandlungen aber die Frage ist
wodurch wird man an den
Verhandlungstisch gezwungen
ich nenne keine konkrete Zahl weil am
Ende die zentrale also die zentrale
variable und die wir schauen müssen ist
die Veränderungen in der russischen
Führung und da haben wir extrem
schlechtes Verständnis dessen was da
passiert und wie sich die Position
wandeln wenn die Lage so bleibt wie sie
jetzt bleibt müssen wir uns leider auf
einen sehr langen Konflikt vorbereiten
Herr mangott was ist ihre Antwort darauf
auf die Frage wie lange das gehen können
ich denke wir können nicht wissen wann
und wie dieser Krieg endet und es ist
auch nicht richtig dass jeder mit
Verhandlungen ändert sich erinnere nur
an den Zweiten Weltkrieg da wurde das
Ende des Krieges auch nicht verhandelt
sondern es wurde militärisch entschieden
und es ist eben die Aufgabe der Aufgabe
der Politik zu entscheiden wo sie die
größere Gerechtigkeit sieht und die
größere verwirklichungsmöglichkeit in
einem militärischen Sieg der Ukraine mit
anderen eskalationsrisiken oder doch in
Verhandlungen aber Behandlungen im
Augenblick das gebe ich dann auch zu
sind völlig aussichtslos beide Seiten
wollen nicht verhandeln beide haben ganz
unterschiedliche Ziele also selbst eine
Vermittlungsmission um solche
Verhandlungen auf den Weg zu bringen hat
im Augenblick überhaupt keine Chance
vielleicht der Aussichten Frau Melnik
auf was stellt man sich in der Ukraine
ein eigentlich
wichtig ist jetzt auch darüber
nachzudenken welche Position wir in den
Verhandlungen stärken wollen und ich
glaube für mich steht aus der Frage dass
wir die Position der Ukraine stärken
sollen das heißt es auch durch
Waffenlieferungen und dass dieser Krieg
nicht über Jahre hinzieht in der
Ukrainisch rechnet man auch damit dass
man die im besten die größten Erfolge im
Jahr 23 erreicht und ich glaube wir
müssen alles tun dass das wirklich
passiert aber man stellt sich auch
darauf ein dass es eben noch auf jeden
Fall ins nächste Jahr geht das sind
keine guten Aussichten ich bedanke mich
für die Diskussion herr Krüger Herr
Lippmann Herr Mangold nach Innsbruck
herzliche Grüße und Frau Melnik und
vielen dank ihnen fürs Interesse es gibt
morgen wieder eine Phoenix Runde dann
schauen wir auf die Innenpolitik und
Fragen nämlich Regieren in der Krise wie
geschlossen ist diese Ampelkoalition
eigentlich ist schön wenn sie dabei sind
und jetzt folgt der Tag mit meiner
Kollegin Konstanze abratzki bis dann
tschüss
[Musik]